good morning Hank it's Thursday it's the
fourth day of pizza miss and I have just
one thing to say yeah thank you for
including this in your video Nick
because I actually think about this man
a lot I call him cheese doodles guy and
my current number-one goal in life is to
someday be as excited about something as
cheese doodles guy is about cheese
doodles so it's a weird facet of human
brains but some things cause that joyful
excitement and others don't like today
the World Health Organization announced
that maternal death over the last 25
years has fallen 44% worldwide this is
amazing news arguably even better news
than discovering cheese doodles in
Antarctica and yet while I'm encouraged
by this news I am NOT cheese doodles guy
excited about it which is so weird
humans are so weird but anyway I think
this video isn't about cheese doodles
it's Thursday it's question Thursday the
day that I answer real questions from
real nerdfighters let's get right to it
why did you shave your beard I just
started don't like it too mostly for the
mustache joke but also it's kind of
itchy who is your least favorite Beatle
and what is your least favorite color
Ringo silver that's a funny name I feel
like Ringo silver would have a mustache
and maybe a curious hat and a pet monkey
and together they would solve crimes hey
how many Pizza John shirts can you wear
at the same time oh I can wear all of
them and fairly comfortably as it turns
out nonetheless I think I'm gonna stick
with just the one for now do you know
any more dad jokes
I feel like dad jokes aren't something
you know so much is there something you
are like every time I'm putting away the
dishes I always say Tupperware
Tupperware Tupperware and then I go to
the Tupperware drawer and then Sarah
looks at me with just absolute disgust
pizza or pizza it's always pizza how do
you feel about vegetables they're great
on pizza what should I get my boyfriend
for Christmas might I recommend Pizza
John shoelaces the perfect gift for
someone who has everything except for a
way to keep their shoes on available
only during pizza mess at dftba.com
what's your opinion on a licorice
strongly in favor how do you become
well-read I don't know I mostly read
books that are recommended to me by
people that I trust but I will give you
a book recommendation this amazing weird
sci-fi book midnight robber I love it
would you consider getting a real tattoo
now that you've gotten a fake one well I
don't think my tattoo is fake it was
just made with water instead of ink so
it's not technically visible
still real I would consider getting more
invisible tattoos what do you think
about ducks well I spent an inordinate
amount of time thinking about what
happens to them when the pond freezes
over in winter I'll tell you that how do
you become okay with being truly alone
okay so I would argue that you're both
never and always truly alone like you're
always truly alone in the sense that no
one can ever fully comprehend your
experience or live inside your
consciousness so you're also never truly
alone but but just like by virtue of
living or having left that comment
you're part of this massive
interconnected web of life on earth and
that web is grateful to have you here
and when I can remember that it helps
give me the energy to connect more
meaningfully with other people whether
it's online or in real life and in turn
that makes me feel more aware of this
big web that I'm part of which makes me
feel less alone what is the opposite of
guacamole aloma cog in 50 years what
country do you think will be the world's
biggest superpower I think in general
nation states will be slightly less
important than they are now but I'm
gonna say India what's your favorite
research chemical what am i Walter White
what should I get my girlfriend for our
three year anniversary let me answer
your question with a question does your
girlfriend enjoy drinking liquids
because if so she might enjoy this pizza
John travel mug available for pre-order
only during Pizza Mass at dftba.com how
do I deal with the death of my Candace
well things will get easier with time
but I think for a while at least you're
gonna feel a little prickly I'm sorry I
hate myself
do you still any leftover Halloween
candy if you mean does your two-year-old
daughter still have some leftover
Halloween candy and you eat it
occasionally because she's too and won't
notice then yes
hey Cappy pizza Monsieur no you know I'm
excited about pizza missile just not
that excited I'll see you tomorrow